but it's also cost-effective.
It turns out fish is the most cost-effective protein
on the planet.
If you look at how much fish protein you get
per dollar invested
compared to all of the other animal proteins,
obviously, fish is a good business decision.
It also doesn't need a lot of land,
something that's in short supply,
compared to other protein sources.
And it doesn't need a lot of fresh water.
It uses a lot less fresh water than,
for example, cattle,
where you have to irrigate a field
so that you can grow the food to graze the cattle.
It also has a very low carbon footprint.
It has a little bit of a carbon footprint
because we do have to get out and catch the fish.
It takes a little bit of fuel,
but as you know, agriculture can have a carbon footprint,
and fish has a much smaller one,
so it's less polluting.
It's already a big part of our diet,
but it can be a bigger part of our diet,
which is a good thing, because we know
that it's healthy for us.
It can reduce our risks of cancer,
heart disease and obesity.
In fact, our CEO Andy Sharpless,
who is the originator of this concept, actually,
he likes to say fish is the perfect protein.
Andy also talks about the fact that
our ocean conservation movement really grew
out of the land conservation movement,
and in land conservation,
we have this problem where biodiversity
is at war with food production.
You have to cut down the biodiverse forest
if you want to get the field
to grow the corn to feed people with,
and so there's a constant push-pull there.
There's a constant tough decision
that has to be made between
two very important things:
maintaining biodiversity and feeding people.
But in the oceans, we don't have that war.
In the oceans, biodiversity is not at war
with abundance.
In fact, they're aligned.
When we do things that produce biodiversity,
we actually get more abundance,
and that's important so that we can feed people.
Now, there's a catch.
Didn't anyone get that? (Laughter)
Illegal fishing.
Illegal fishing undermines the type of
sustainable fisheries management I'm talking about.
It can be when you catch fish using gears
that have been prohibited,
when you fish in places where you're not supposed to fish,
you catch fish that are the wrong size or the wrong species.
Illegal fishing cheats the consumer
and it also cheats honest fishermen,
and it needs to stop.
The way illegal fish get into our market is through seafood fraud.
You might have heard about this.
It's when fish are labeled as something they're not.
Think about the last time you had fish.
What were you eating?
Are you sure that's what it was?
Because we tested 1,300 different fish samples
and about a third of them
were not what they were labeled to be.
Snappers, nine out of 10 snappers were not snapper.
Fifty-nine percent of the tuna we tested
was mislabeled.
And red snapper, we tested 120 samples,
and only seven of them were really red snapper,
so good luck finding a red snapper.
Seafood has a really complex supply chain,
and at every step in this supply chain,
there's an opportunity for seafood fraud,
unless we have traceability.
Traceability is a way where the seafood industry
can track the seafood from the boat to the plate
to make sure that the consumer can then find out
where their seafood came from.
This is a really important thing.
It's being done by some in the industry, but not enough,
so we're pushing a law in Congress
called the SAFE Seafood Act,
and I'm very excited today to announce the release
of a chef's petition, where 450 chefs
have signed a petition calling on Congress
to support the SAFE Seafood Act.
It has a lot of celebrity chefs you may know --
Anthony Bourdain, Mario Batali,
Barton Seaver and others —
and they've signed it because they believe
that people have a right to know
about what they're eating.
(Applause)
Fishermen like it too, so there's a good chance
we can get the kind of support we need
to get this bill through,
and it comes at a critical time,
because this is the way we stop seafood fraud,
this is the way we curb illegal fishing,
and this is the way we make sure
that quotas, habitat protection,
and bycatch reductions can do the jobs
they can do.
We know that we can manage our fisheries sustainably.
We know that we can produce
healthy meals for hundreds of millions of people
that don't use the land, that don't use much water,
have a low carbon footprint,
and are cost-effective.
We know that saving the oceans
can feed the world,
and we need to start now.
(Applause)
Thank you. (Applause)